we're traveling along the indus highway
in sindh province between seven sharif
and dadu where we've been reporting from
over the last few days and uh
all this water here this is not a
natural river or a canal this is rain
water from this so-called monster
monsoon it has completely besieged this
area all the homes have water going into
them and the electricity pylons you can
see behind me they're completely
submerged there's no electricity in many
parts pakistan already struggles with
electricity
service and there's no um
telephone signal a lot of lines are down
and internet is wishful thinking in many
parts but beyond that it's the basics
they don't have food
and water and shelter the people here
from the this area they've many of them
have moved out of their own homes and
into makeshift tents some of them
kept back from other
disasters back in 2010 when they had
floods in this area others have used a
piece of clothing and sticks to make
their tents they don't want to leave
their homes they don't want to go too
far into camps or or move along like
we've seen in the last few days other
people have moved to other areas where
they can fly dry find dry land but they
want to stay close to their homes
they're hoping the water will recede
but that also means while they stay
close to this water they are washing in
it they are drinking from it and of
course
there are no bathrooms around here this
is sewage water mixed with this monsoon
water and there is a serious concern for
water-borne diseases